be fill it lean meat with little fine
sinews of fat running through it just
melts in your mouth like butter seasoned
hot pan olive oil seal
mustard
think about it Finnick beef weddings in
English mustard you never put Dijon
mushrooms
season blitz
now go take the water out of my shoes
look how wet they are you don't put oil
or butter into the pan and put nothing
in there
look how much water's coming out now
assemblé
clean film Parma ham
mushrooms
beef center and roll
twist it nice and tight chill 20 minutes
puff pastry
please unwrap
on to the pastry egg wash
don't skip an egg wash now because we
really needed to stick
[Music]
type that in chill five minutes
Blaz
[Music]
school
rock salt
baked
[Applause]
[Music]
the most important thing about filler be
wiling to do not slice it thinly okay
turn it round the slice it about an inch
thick
beef wellington
done you can hear that
[Music]
that is amazing and pull it down toward
you and roll that nice and tightly